program is professor david donahoe from
stanford university so i believe
everyone in the room knows david and his
achievements so i will not spend more
time on the introduction they just start
this exciting talk thanks david
maybe really hard for me to get started
nancy and you have welcomed us
into your home in faith
i'm so sorry
and uh we really appreciate
the friendship that you've shown over
the years
i love the pictures in the slideshow
the the picture of madeleine with you is
very touching
and you introduced us to her and then
[Music]
we saw her as we went around berkeley
and would talk with her and interact and
uh
it was just very touching to feel the
extended family
i
we were invited say to passover seders
we were invited to family weddings at
the brazilian room and
so many more moments
[Music]
but also there's a lot of professional
moments that
sometimes by random chance
i happen to be around for those and you
may you may not be aware of all of these
but um
well okay when you were elected to nas
there was a party at the
department here in evans hall
uh same thing with macarthur fellowship
but um actually we were in israel and
saw you get your honorary degree
from hebrew university on mount scopus
looking down
over the dead sea
yeah that just happened
also i had the good fortune to see you
get an honorary degree at eteha
and i guess there was the knighting or
whatever it's called
in princeton these are a lot of
important professional moments
and uh
somehow they've all happened in your
life but they've also happened in my
life and it's the the fact that i've
been able
to be part of that really
accumulates over your lot over anyway my
life
and uh so i also have to say thank you
well to you for having all these
professional successes
but uh a number of people in the
audience made these things possible
so
uh
and then there are people who are not
here or no longer with us that i
won't be able to mention but
um
you know as we saw john xing enabled the
princeton moment
and uh peter bulman
enabled the eth moment and lisa and all
of her sidekicks have enabled this
moment and this is going to be very
memorable to me
stacking on all the other moments so
okay so
this is kind of
how i first met peter pretty much i
would say around this age
with this kind of demeanor
and he was always very calm i love what
lisa said
that he always assumes the best about
people it just feels like exactly that's
who he is and that's part of the magic
as we'll see that
he's got a tremendous cast of
collaborators and that wouldn't be so
without the kind of
psychological mojo that he puts into his
relationships
so i really treasure the moments that
he was counseling me in my early career
and i know there are many other people
who had similar moments
and were sort of a loyal band
on your side
another thing is that doesn't come from
nowhere i think it's it's kind of
important to realize
that there was an earlier generation
that had
also very positive attitude part of it
was
what comes from being
you know at the pinnacle
vertically in those days in many
dimensions
was
so far ahead of so many other places
that it was a kind of
uh well we just heard about supremacy
but it was it was a kind of qualitative
superiority
that uh you know
couldn't have been
anywhere before except maybe
i don't know in math under david hill
bird something like that you know uh i i
just love the look here of david
blackwell because
it sort of indicates the alertness
confidence and so on and you can see
that eric layman is very kind person
and you can see you know peter is young
with this energy and
and he's just a very positive person
okay so let's talk about peter's
scholarship
you're at about a thousand citations per
year in google scholar every year you've
been alive so that means
you didn't get all that you started
quite early
uh
you know various things have have
produced that and will continue to
produce citations over time
and it was very interesting i went
through you know at this point
so many dozens of papers and there are a
lot of papers in your profile i didn't
even know about
and um
my favorites that i think are just
incredible
are sometimes not even visible like
they're just tiny little
citations compared to some of the others
uh so i just thought i'd go you know
decade by decade and you can see here
even so this is in the google scholar
era and there's a lot of things that
have been erased because of internet
and yet
here are these papers that were written
in the 60s by peter still being
cited today at
you know
rates that would be significant for many
members of the audience had they just
been written now
uh in in
and
some of these are on robustness but
there's a great deal of variety
here it's
and so i'll know more about the
robustness story but other people will
know about lots of other things
and
then we go into the 70s and their things
on non-parametric density estimation
there's a data analysis project on
sex bias and graduate admissions that
became a total classic
there's a variety of papers on
robustness and
and so on
then we get into the 80s there's a
canonical paper on the bootstrap there's
the foundation of the subject of
semi-parametric estimation
there's the squabble with
uh
dr cox and george box
and there's a great foundational paper
peter with
yaakov rito
which you know rocked my world when it
came out and
and so on so that there's a lot there
but then it continues in the 90s
and
you know i'm not an expert on all of
these papers that's actually the thing
that's very
striking about this i thought i knew
peter i realized i know
a fraction maybe a fraction of a
fraction of peter and and uh it's a lot
of work to keep up with the scope
of what he's been doing
so in the arts this continues and he's
moved into high dimensional statistics
and and network models
and
then in the last decade i guess there's
a reissue of his book with shell which
is getting
a fresh huge collection of citations in
that decade he's also working in
comp bio and getting tons of sites
associated with that
maybe this is a re
reissue of the
original work of
bickle guts and von sweat that came out
associated maybe with
uh memorial volume etc so
uh but it's still a lot of sites and
then it continues into this decade and
i just heard about some work of his that
i plan to cite
so there's going to be future citations
this is the the curve over time so that
the bars here
are indicating
decade by decade what's going on
[Music]
so
better
[Music]
okay safe
so you can see here total citations
scaling up so 16 000
in the teens decade that we've recently
left
if we can just look at publications
issued per decade and the max citations
of any publication
it's all heading up
and it's accelerating recently
this is uh like really really impressive
um
i wanted to say that despite you know
all of this i have a lot of favorite
papers there's a lot of things that
peter has done that
are
impactful but some of it is
not high on the list of citations at
this time
the world is you know interested in
other things at this moment but i
thought i just mentioned in my own life
what's been important
so peter
from his early citations on robustness
that i mentioned to you
was i guess invited to participate in a
princeton robustness year which issued
the book on the left on which he's
a co-author
and he got to interact with john tukey
who was my undergraduate advisor
and
about as different from the berkeley way
of doing things as could be and somehow
peter got along with him collaborated
and something useful came out of
out of this this book which you know i
have
a well-thumbed copy
uh
sort of described the first
you know
computational experiment
on a whole bunch of conjectures that
reach sort of a high scale
and was trying to implement a whole
paradigm of doing these things i had
never seen that before i'd never seen
anything like it in journals
so i found it fascinating
now
i i was fine hall there when you were
there for that year okay so so there's
fine hall the math building
because of the success of that book
i guess
um the math department at princeton and
the stat group
got
funded
pdp-11 that was running the first unix
outside of bill labs
and by my sophomore year i was the
manager of this computer
and so the success of that book which
put princeton in such high esteem on
robustness
got them this computer which got me the
job which got me into statistics
so there's there are levels of impact
that are happening behind the scenes
here that you can't simply see from the
citations
so
my job was to write stat software there
was nothing at the time
so i wrote a stat package which was
called isp at the time
and what made it a useful package let's
see if i have the right things here
um
well i these are a bunch of papers that
i learned as a sophomore
and just like you know rocked my world
and you know review articles on
robustness and this paper is very
important for maybe what comes next
characterizing
asymptotic variants of lots of
estimators and comparisons with variance
of the mean and so on okay but this
paper
for for those of you who think peter's
not applied
so
so this paper
is what i think made isp possible namely
it allowed to compute
robust estimates in this this is stat
package right and the you know
princeton robustness study has just been
done so this stat software better be
able to do something right and in that
dimension
so
what it did was based on this or you
know obviously it had various options
but this is one of them and i remember
carefully reading this paper
implementing it and so on
and
i was just a wild you know junior at
this point and no one was telling me
what to do so i just did it i
implemented it
and
the software worked and
before i knew it the the
stat group at princeton was
distributing it
all around to the unix cities that were
being
you know proliferating
so eventually the berkeley people i
think with jim reeds
started using that
so i think the popularity of the package
was that it could actually do this like
you couldn't
at the time really get
robust linear model calculations but you
could through this package which was by
just and it happened to implement this
because some crazy junior read this
paper
uh then it be then berkeley took it over
and the stat lab was the worldwide
distributor of the package which they
renamed blss
and there was a staff
here that was maintaining it improving
and they went far beyond anything i
could ever have imagined
but a key thing is that in that staff
a person was ross ihaka
ross was a founder of r
and so
like what really happened here is the
computability through this paper spawned
a package which spread around
then it led to to actually being able to
pay staff and it led ultimately to
foundational work that gave us r
by bringing more talent into the field
first just showing them
a stat package that you know an
undergraduate could have thought of and
then let's do better
so those are some consequences you may
not have
thought of of your work it's just the
ability to compute something
can
go through a series of chain reactions
okay well
a series of canonical papers that i
became aware of as a graduate student
and after
as listed here and they're all not about
robustness
but the key thing that you have to know
is that the first one has an important
discovery of peter's
and at about the same time i think you
know boris levite and
alfie moratzi had
something touching on this
which is
[Music]
uh the calculation of
bayes risk
in a normal mean estimation problem with
squared error loss
is isomorphic
to the calculation of
the asymptotic variance of the kind that
you would do in robust estimation
this came out of the fact that in the
60s peter had papers both on bay's risk
problems and on robustness he knew both
of these things so he could make that
discovery
now the the
connection is deeper than just say the
the exact value of the base risk tells
you the exact value
of an asymptotic variance it's actually
that
the exact optimal bayes rule
is rigidly connected to the exact
optimal
scoring function that you would have to
be using to get the
you know correct uh
uh asymptotic variants according to this
formula so there's there's an actual
isomorphism between robustness
uh and
granted you know in a scalar univariate
problem
and
[Music]
bay's risk
for one observation in that scalar
univariate problem and then once you
understand that or peter understood that
you can
do several problems all at once and and
he does a few of these
uh just speaking on behalf of ian like
ian later has papers where he
figures this all out in the poisson case
and so on a lot of other people at the
conference might have been influenced by
this i'm just mentioning things i know
personally so if i'm forgetting to
mention you please
uh
you know we're
trying to get somewhere uh
in referring to some things that
probably can't refer to everything
uh
out of this actually there's a last
paper here so john collins was here
yesterday but
he had to go early
and i was speaking to him about this so
i think if you look at the third one of
these which appeared in sankia
it kind of
summarizes everything
that's needed from the others if you you
know can can decode it
and there he's trying to
uh just discuss the problem of we have
uh families of
distributions and we want to minimize
the fisher information over that
this comes out of a paper it's not
really paper it's a problem
that was posed in siam in the problem
section by colin mallows
who's a very distinguished
statistician applied mathematician at
bell labs
back in the day and peter has you know
written papers on the mallows metric
and he's written papers on solving this
specific problem and so on and so forth
uh let's minimize the fischer
information over
mixtures of distributions
so mallows had an idea for one such
problem
and
talked about it's frustrating that
he couldn't solve it and
here's a guess
and so on and so forth
so
peter and john's paper looked at that
and several others
and they described that there's a
interesting discreteness property of all
such solutions
and they spoke about the connection
to
finding the least favorable distribution
for over classes of priors
and they spoke about the connection to
the hoover problem of finding the least
favorable distribution for contamination
and robustness problems
so they identified this as being really
central to
two central problems in statistics and
they you know characterize things
now i spoke to john yesterday and
you know by the rules of whatever was
true you know what whatever how one
played the game of publishing in those
days
uh you might know something numerically
about this problem but you could never
publish a thing about it it would there
was just no outlet or anything
you know you you just silence unless
there was
a closed-form symbolic expression
then there's nothing you know it doesn't
exist so
what one cannot
reduce the closed form and prove
therefore one must be silent
where the rules of the day i don't think
that we have those rules anymore in fact
i'll discuss how they've changed a
little bit later okay how are we doing
for time
okay so
i just wanna you know so
coming out of this
i'll just say it's it's influenced
uh my own work
in a couple of ways
and i don't uh
i can't list them all and so on and so
forth but uh in some way i've worked on
the problem that's associated with
his uh
first paper here
um
[Music]
in comparing the
minimax mse minimax
bays risk
over a restricted parameter space
between a linear estimator a non-linear
estimator
and ian johnstone and i have
you know
looked at this particular problem as
well
peter you know completely
defined the whole problem of
what if you have
a need to estimate really well at one
given point
then how much does that hurt your risk
everywhere else that's somehow
isomorphic
to
what if um
you have a
prior distribution that's a sparse prior
that has a great deal of mass at one
point and then you know the other mass
is spread out in some way
um
and
and so this which
might not seem
relevant um
to noise removal of sparse signals at
like a you know course level is like
isomorphic to it so the work that ian
and i did is
is kind of teasing out the consequences
of that so it goes on and on there's a
lot a lot that one could
uh pull out of that line of work and and
uh
just not that much time
now
but i i wanted to to say
something that that came out of those
three papers
for me anyway
which is a family of work
that was done with
andrea montanari
and a psg student at the time ariane
maleki who's now
on the faculty at columbia
and
this was the development of an algorithm
called amp
which
essentially what the algorithm showed is
that conceptually if you
under sample by not getting enough
measurements
it's the same thing as complete data but
just adding noise
of course the measurements have to be
collected in a special way
but that's exactly what compressed
sensing is about and so it was just
transforming
you know
only collecting 10 of the data you need
to
getting
a significant amount more noise
on a completely observed signal
so that's what this this paper was about
once you understand that then you
understand that
if you have sparsity and you can do
noise removal using some of the ideas
that are
kind of implicit in that work
uh then it it would be possible to
recover something
the unusual thing is the notion of phase
transition
where
in under sampling
you can do computational experiments
that will show you that for a given
amount of sparsity
which could be measured in some way on
this axis
there's a certain amount of
incompleteness or under sampling such
that
up to a certain point
you're gonna
i'm assuming noiseless data to begin
with
but very undersampled up to a certain
point you can exactly recover the
underlying object
so so we knew these curves
by you know experimental means and there
was combinatorial geometry and so on and
so forth
but um
in this work which includes in at this
point what we what we found is that
if you look at
a curve of the min max risk as a
function
of
the non-zeroness parameter which is a
thing that peter first defined in
in the paper in the churn off best strip
then depending on the estimator you're
using and what the rules of the game are
these curves actually gave you the
previous curves there's an exact
isomorphism between the curves there's
just a deterministic rule that turns
once you know this you know the other
one
um
and uh one thing that we found
interesting is
this red curve here
which is one of the
things that
peter wanted like his his paper with
john collins wanted
well it defined
so we computed it
and we computed the solution of the
mallow's problem numerically
and computed this curve and by the old
rules of
publication that has no
status it could never be published ah
but we turned it into science namely we
then went out and made measurements
uh
you know experimentally
of actual algorithms and showed that
they exactly fell along these curves
so then it's a it's a prediction and
it's solving in this particular case
uh a non-convex optimization but
today we would say it's actually fully
rigorously solving it as long as you're
within this regime
okay and and i could tell you more it's
it's this is all in that in the paper
that i cited with
ian and andrea
now
at about the time that paper appeared
so nourah dean
and peter bickle and
uh
bean who i don't know
uh issued two papers in pnas
and you know these were fantastic papers
where they're doing m estimation in this
high dimensional regression limit these
are great papers i just want to point
out like by citations they're way down
in in the
peter over
even for the fact that they're less than
a decade old but you know if i were
given 100 votes i would give 100 to each
of them or 50 or whatever i'm allowed
so
andrea and i understood this in a
different way maybe or maybe the same
way but we understood that
what we had done
with approximate message passing and
this equivalence between incompleteness
of data and denoising
was equivalent by the same isomorphism
that peter first discovered namely
the problem in robustness in this case
robust regression is isomorphic
to a problem in
bayes decision theory in this case noise
removal from sparse signals
and
the other thing that is kind of amazing
is
some things that that in peter's
original one-dimensional problem were a
little bit like gaps
where
there was a difference between the huber
contamination model and the kind of
model
that
colin mallows was mentioning that
disappeared
like in in in
because there's some gaussian extra
noise that
that we had seen
in the bayes side of the equation
and that peter and neuradine had seen in
the robustness side of the equation
so
just because of that we could
write this paper which is is just
using the approach by approximate
message passing
to it
instead of doing a denoising compressed
sensing type problem it could be done
do it for robust regression
and then just to come back to peter's
the first paper that i ever listed here
was a paper that that peter wrote
where he he's calculating the asymptotic
variance
of the huber m estimator and various
other kinds of estimators as annals of
statistics 1965
and
something that was very important in
peter huber's mind
was that
the
hoover m estimator could you its
variants could never blow up
uh in the same way that say humble
estimator or many other
uh canonical estimators you could
contaminate them to make the variants
blow up but in this high dimensional
limit
that's no longer true so i just
i came home from
[Music]
i think peter's
degree ceremony at aha
decided hey you know at which we had
lunch
with peter peter huber and effie
and said okay this that's what this is
going on here
is that
actually
there's
a relationship that
uber knew many years ago but now in the
high dimensional limit there's a
different relationship which is like
almost as simple
but that
shows that the variance of the
uber am estimator can be
infinite
outside of a kind of phase transition
so
uh that sort of tied together a package
of my phd advisor peter's early work
like a lot of things coming together
peter's isomorphism between
bay's decision problems and robustness
problems like
i know this is all sounding very vague
but it's a long long story to get to
every detail in the package
and then there's some other work which
i've been doing
a lot with with for example ian and
other authors that's all inspired by
this and i don't have time really to get
to it i think right isn't that true
um
[Music]
okay
so
i've shown you these site counts
and
we've looked a little bit at the past
what about
the future
well
we're off to good start in this decade
uh and maybe if we impute
we're about a fourth of the way through
the decade
and if we impute you know
by factor four then we'll see that
you're you're at least at the same place
that's at least the current rate which
is
unbelievable
across seven decades acceleration
monotony like
my mind is so blown
um
so at this point we're
at a place where
peter has
you know biographies written about him
like this one by
indian statistical institute for a talk
that he recently gave and you can you
can go read it and it looks
it looks pretty like you know complete
that's that's like a complete story of a
scientific career it goes on and on i'm
just showing you the first page
now
so recently
david cox passed away
and in the uh journal significance and
actually very recent edition the cover
has this quote from
sir david cox which where he says in a
sense the only thing that matters is if
you can look back when you reach a vast
vast age and say have i done something
reasonably in accord with my capability
if you can say yes okay my feeling is in
one sense i've done that
many people would agree
so the thing is you know peter's already
at the stage where he can say that he's
not actually by my book at a vast vast
age
i feel that the
the health and vitality seem to be there
from the outside
um
and maybe a good omen i find the
following thing helpful so you've seen
this picture last night uh there's
peter bickle and he's standing next to
ingram ulkin
who was you know spry well into his 90s
and and there's ted anderson
ted's
widow is my neighbor
so
i just want you to
realize that ted
lived quite a long time
and
even thanks to i think john sheen
published posthumously
99 years after he was born
that's that seems to suggest
that being a statistician
active in publishing
and continuing in the life that we lead
can be correlated with
achievements even into fairly extreme
old age
so
when i look at
what's going on here i'm reminded of the
story of euler who
actually was able to
again possibly you know
publish even after he had passed away
because the editorial staff took time
to publish in those days so things were
appearing for for years after he had
passed away
and
i expect no less from peter
i don't want to put pressure on in the
sense that i don't want to say you know
you have to
compete with any of these people so on
and so forth i do feel it's a very good
indicator to stay active
and and uh ted was you know definitely
very active and involved and so on and
so forth so i certainly hope that
that will be the case
now there's a another
[Music]
nancy i just
so there's another thing which is that
it's very important
um
to be in a relationship and i think
nancy's just
you know the perfect partner for peter
and he's very lucky to have her
um i think that there are some good
indicators for longevity
also based on that
so
at some point
the state of massachusetts decided that
the oldest living couple in
massachusetts
was an eminent statistician
herman chernoff and his wife judy
i think this came out about a year ago
and
you know uh
herman was very active and so on judy
a very uh involved in the community
person
very delightful
so those are those are good indicators
so being a
couple where there's an active
statistician
who's made
penetrating contributions throughout
their career that's also a good
indicator to reach the status of the
oldest living couple in massachusetts
i'm i'm kind of hopeful that the oldest
living couple in california if you
continue to live here will one day be
youtube now
uh an enthusiasm of hermann and judy
was to have the department have dances
in fact my wife and i were at a dance
about
nine years ago at harvard after
[Music]
a seminar there where herman and judy
danced together
so if they made it to the
senior couple of the state of
massachusetts
maybe part of the ingredient is not just
statistics but their dance
interests
now peter and nancy have always been
dancers and i hope you'll keep dancing
through life
as time goes by
that's all
[Applause]
thank you david that's really touching
so any comments
things you want to share
let's thank david yadin and all of the
speakers for the program again
[Applause]